(music)
Hi. I'm John Mitchell. I'm a professor of
Computer Science at Stanford University.
I got a bachelor's degree in Math at
Stanford and I worked for a couple of
years, and I went and, ah, got a graduate
degree in Computer Science at MIT. When I
finished my PhD, I went to go work in an
industrial research lab, which was really
great in some ways, it was the ideal job.
I went in the morning, I had the whole
day to do whatever I want, but sort of after awhile I felt there was something a
little bit repetitive about it. And when
I came out to Stanford it to look at a
teaching job, I thought this would really
be much better. I think there are many,
many interesting things about
cybersecurity. Ah, trying to figure out the
difference between what people want from
technology and the things that we really
don't want, or we consider malicious. It's also really interesting to see how
people's attitudes change over time
about what they want and what they don't
want, what they find uncomfortable in
different ways. Ah, so we have students working
together on web security. Ah, some things
having to do with mobility. And we've
been very interested in the last few
years in privacy, web tracking, ah, things
that have to do with policy. But, but
generally speaking, how do we build
technology that's responsive to the
things that people want to do, and
protects against, ah, malicious things and
give some assurance about privacy and data.
(music)